welcome back to CBS this morning we're
learning startling new details of what
unfolded when FBI agents arrested Gillan
Maxwell at a secluded New Hampshire
mansion
prosecutors say Maxwell tried to hide
when agents approached she's expected to
appear before a New York judge today
accused of helping Jeffrey Epstein
sexually abuse underage girls Maxwell
has denied any wrongdoing national
correspondent Jericka Duncan is at the
Manhattan courthouse tareka what can we
expect in court today
well good morning Anthony Glenn Maxwell
will be appearing here at the same New
York Court for her bail hearing as
Jeffrey Epstein did almost a year ago
today but in this case we're talking
about happening during the middle of a
pandemic and Maxwell's hearing will be
held via video court documents filed by
ghilane Maxwell's attorneys claimed the
58 year old British socialite who they
say hasn't left the country since
Jeffrey Epstein's arrest last July is
not a flight risk her legal team is
offering a five million dollar bail
package to secure her release that
funding is backed by six co-signers
Maxwell siblings relatives and friends
and includes property in the UK valued
at roughly three point seven five
million dollars CBS News legal analyst
Rickey Clements says Maxwell's attorneys
faced a major burden in advocating for
her bail but have made a solid case the
defense wrote a very persuasive
memorandum more important perhaps even
than the package is the reasoning number
one over 19 that not only might killed
Elaine Maxwell would certainly would not
benefit the victims of Jeffrey Epstein
and allegedly of ghilane Maxwell but
secondly what they argue is the fact
that she would never hide it it is
possible that Maxwell steam says she
simply left the public eye to avoid
media attention and scrutiny but
prosecutors believe Maxwell has tried to
hide before and does present
flight risk according to court documents
when FBI agents approached Maxwell's new
hampshire home she fled to another room
investigators also claimed they noticed
a cell phone wrapped in tinfoil which
prosecutors called a seemingly misguided
effort to evade law enforcement the same
documents revealed Maxwell is linked to
more than a dozen bank accounts around
the world worth more than 20 million
dollars in total and has three passports
in her name
last summer Jeffrey Epstein died by
hanging while awaiting trial at the
Metropolitan Correctional Center in
Manhattan it prompted intense scrutiny
over how the jail was run and outraged
on behalf of the Epstein accusers who
were unable to face him in court Maxwell
is being held in a similar facility
roughly five miles from where Epstein
died since her arrival at the
Metropolitan Detention Center in
Brooklyn details have emerged about
what's being done to protect Maxwell law
enforcement officials confirmed to CBS
News that Maxwell sheets were taken away
and she wore prison-issue clothes made
of paper I think you have to assume
people do want her dead Cameron Lindsey
served as the warden of the Brooklyn
Jail from 2007 to 2009 where Maxwell is
currently being held miss Maxwell
allegedly knows some very very damaging
information about a multitude of
allegedly very important people it is
just absolutely essential that the
government get this right and safeguard
her not only for the sake of all the
victims involved but for the sake of
unmasking other potential co-defendants
Maxwell's attorneys maintained they've
been in touch with prosecutors since
Jeffrey Epstein was arrested last year
the allegations in this indictment
against Maxwell they include charges
that date back to 1994 and involve three
underage girls
Gail Thank You jury Co a lot of girls
very happy that she's behind bars we'll
see how this turns out thank you very
much